today's speed round is brought to you by
verizon and let's get to it the chris
sims mock draft from the perspective of
how
some of these picks might be received
chris and let's start at selection
number 12 the eagles traded down from
six cornerback jc horn i think peter
king has the same guy going to the
eagles
word association what is the eagles fan
reaction if that happens i think they're
going to be like happy they're gonna be
like man look at this guy this big
physical freak corner we need help there
you know that was one where listen i
don't love jc horn the player i don't
but there's just too many people that
got him linked to the philadelphia
eagles and for them for again again
they're gonna run a seattle type of
scheme a little bit he fits that as far
as the mold of that type of corner
rather than one that's gonna lock down
people one on one so you know fans
everybody thinks the scene he's awesome
i'm in the minority here i think there's
going to be a good reaction with it
first of all i don't think eagles fans
and happy
i don't think that co-exists right now
they're not going to be happy until they
get another super bowl because they they
got a taste of one and they want more
and they want them now um and i like i i
think that i think that they'll be like
okay all right that's that's what
everyone's expecting yeah let's see if
the guy can play and let's see if we can
address some of these many other needs
we have later in the draft i think that
the astute eagles fan would be hoping
for a trade down and more picks because
they have so many needs to address the
big thing is mike like who's the trade
up for
that's the thing i think that we're
going to get into this like a lot of
teams are gonna look to trade down but
we know there's lack of marquee
superstar players in this draft so i
once you get past 10
i don't know who everyone's trading up
for it's like a nice talk and thought
and everything like that but it's a
limited amount of players i think that's
kind of one of the things i'm interested
to see you know thursday night
well on peter king's formulation devante
smith the heisman trophy winner makes it
all the way to 15 and we talked
yesterday that 10 to 10 to 15
range would be the sweet spot for
somebody yeah who loves him right you
say i'm gonna go get him that opens the
door yeah a lot of people want to trade
down
you got to find a team
that is in love with a prospect that
thinks he's going to be a huge
difference maker and that sees him slide
into striking distance and they mobilize
just like that to go get it you're right
because other than that the trades
aren't going to happen because everyone
is trading up
for a specific player when the trade up
happens during the draft all right what
will my reaction be
if the vikings take usc's elijah vera
tucker at number 14. well
who writes these
your best friend matt casey
[Laughter]
so so what's what's your viking what's
viking superfan florio what's the
reaction if you take all offensive line
there
first of all i am not a super fan oh
baloney if i hate i hate all teams
equally and i hate you even more
uh hey you know the thing about the
draft is
everyone wants
the sexy
skill position
fantasy football pick the guy whose
jersey you're going to want to buy no
one's going to want to buy an offensive
lineman's jersey but
you need as i said yesterday
infrastructure to let the other guys
operate kirk cousins needs the
infrastructure they got rid of riley
reef i don't know that ezra cleveland's
the answer at left tackle and you need
the guy that can do the the kubiak they
traded one kubiak for the other clint is
going to be running the offense right
the same scheme you need somebody who
can come in and help that offensive line
be better and that's where the vikings
have focused in the first round yeah in
recent years
and second round they're trying to make
that offensive line better because they
don't have a patrick mahomes who can run
around all day long and buy time the
offensive line buys the time for their
quarterback yeah no doubt i mean they
get the way they play is it's set up by
their offensive line and the ability to
open up holes from dalvin cook that's
really that's the jump off point for
everything else on their offense
everything else in their offense doesn't
work so well really when they can't do
that so vera tucker you know can be i
think is a left tackle and can play left
tackle but at the very worst he's going
to be a really awesome guard for a long
time so i don't think there's like you
can't miss with him in my opinion as far
as what he can do for the vikings
offensive line but like let me ask you
this mike just as a the super fan that
you are of the vikings will you shut up
would you would you be mad though if
like
you know jalen phillips quitty pay like
those type of guys edge pass rushers
would you rather have that on your
football team right now than the
offensive line
i think the vikings have a greater need
right now at pass rusher than they do at
offensive line although
they've got so much invested in kirk
cousins financially they have to make
that work 35 million fully guaranteed
salary next year they've got to make
that work period so i think that's the
way it's going to go and then they'll
try to find pass rushers later in the
draft uh
despite the fact that it is a greater
need right now all right giants fan
reaction if gay if dave gettleman the gm
of the team who never trades down the
giants haven't traded down since 2006.
what's their reaction if they trade back
and get the penn state edge rusher jason
noah i mean i'm a big fan of jason uh i
think it's i think it's old way i
believe oh wait oh wow yeah i know
we'll get it when he gets lots of sacks
in the nfl look i'm i'm a huge fan of
this player now the big thing is mike is
he didn't get a lot of sacks sacks
aren't that easy in college football
first off i mean it's rpos it's read
option it's screen it's screen it's
screen i mean you could go 15 drop back
passes where the quarterback doesn't
really
drop back to let a pass rush get to him
so that's where i think that's
misleading and for me again he might not
be my favorite pass rusher in the draft
but he's a freak of nature there's true
edge need there for the new york
football giants and
and
i just believe it's the type of player
that the giants and the patriots would
believe in to be an edge guy they
believe in length uh when it comes to
those edge guys especially the new
england joe judge patrick graham so
that's where i don't think acquitty pay
is their type of player on the edge i
think they would favor an oa who's more
of like a leonard floyd who again not a
sack master but i'd take leonard floyd
on my team any day of the week he's one
of the best edge defenders in football
and i think away can be a lot like him
yeah and and hey when the giants have
been really good in recent years i've
said this time and again great offensive
line great defense yeah it's easy to get
caught up in the skill position players
but it's the line on both sides that
make a team
great you can have plenty and there are
plenty of great skill position players
throughout the league and they will
continue to be the difference is going
to come
from
how well you can block
on offense and how much chaos you can
create on defense for those great skill
position players what will aaron rodgers
reaction be if as you've projected the
packers take florida receiver cadarius
tony at number 29. yeah i you know i
mean i would hope he'd be really damn
happy and i mean again this is a i think
a need for this football team another
playmaker on the offensive side of the
football
definitely i mean could they be in the
middle linebacker conversation maybe if
there's one there but i think really all
the first round linebackers are going to
be off the board by the time they pick
you know so that that's where you know i
came away with green bay going all right
yeah i know they could maybe use an
offensive lineman i'm not sure if
there's it's that desperate and tony
is like i don't he's tyree killish you
know he's not quite as fast as tyree
kill no human is but it's it's that type
of player mike to where you know i think
green bay could use him as their their
debo samuel right and the 49ers system
the speed sweeps the toss reverses the
the occasional actual sweep and have
people blocking them that way hey play
action pass oh backside slam
cadarius tony he's one on one oh man
he's running like his hair is on fire
through the middle of the defense that's
the kind of guy he is he's a weapon who
could use a little more polish at
receiver but he's too freaky for me to
think he gets out of the first round so
i'm going with the green bay taking him
he better be happy i hope so
would rogers rather have your guy from
north carolina deomi brown that that's i
that's like i love deomi brown and i
like him more than cadarius tony
the only thing i would say is
you know he's a little bit they have a
marquez valdez scandling who is that
deep guy take the top off the defense so
i just wondered hey yeah he's not as
good as diamond brown but
my logic was like they need to find a
different type of guy to round out you
know the receiving core that was kind of
my logic there but i love meeting some
dyami brown and i don't think it's
far-fetched i think he does squeeze in
at the end of the first round
i just can't help but wonder whether the
packers with those receivers that are
going to be there just like last year
you know you you cranked the finger on
aaron rodgers as you continue this
awkward
tug of war and back and forth last year
they didn't draft a single receiver so
we'll see if they they get somebody
either to help aaron rodgers now or
jordan love in the future when the draft
rolls around in just two days let's take
a break when we return a draft focused
on
the war rooms that we'd most like to be
in this year for the draft we'll do that
when pft live continues right after this
pro football talk is brought to you by
verizon built right for business
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports